Thanks thanks so much for the warm
welcome Dickon it's a pleasure to be
here I'm going to tell you a little bit
about the work if we could bring down
the lights in the front might show the
children resolution better there you go
so evolution has produced all of the
genomes of the life forms that we find
on this planet today and they're all
strongly related these are the
vertebrates or at least a small number
of the sixty thousand different
vertebrate species and over the course
of six hundred million years or so
changes to the DNA passed down from
generation to generation have caused an
incredible proliferation of successful
vertebrate life forms on the planet and
we're we're one of those we have a
spiring project to sequence 10,000 of
these vertebrate genomes now from
different species so that we can compare
them and understand the trajectory of
the evolutionary changes that created
this marvelous diversity not only do we
want to sequence the genomes of these
species but we want to collect cells
from them that we can now transform into
what are called induced pluripotent stem
cells or IPS cells from which then we
can differentiate in a dish different
types of tissues from these different
species making what were previously
organisms that were unsteady about by
molecular biology suddenly like model
organisms that can be fully studied so
then we can really see molecular
evolution in action both from a computer
science point of view by comparing the
changes in computing the DNA changes
that have happened by genome comparison
and by looking at the behavior of those
changes in the cells in a dish and there
are a number of other exciting goals
that we will achieve here not only
understanding ourselves as one of these
evolutionary products but understanding
the health and welfare and
other issues with the other species
including endangered species I would say
from a computational point of view
combined with the lab work the grand
challenge at this point is now that we
have the capacity to sequence an entire
DNA sequence from every base in a genome
can we actually reconstruct the
evolutionary trajectory of those bases
all previous work in this area has been
very crude talking at scales that are
above the single base level except for
particular bases and proteins that have
been intensively studied there's a vast
dark matter between the genes in the
vertebrate genome whose evolution is
poorly understood at this point we can
recognize the signs of selection by
comparing the genomes we find
ultraconserved regions that have changed
hardly at all over 600 million years
interspersed with rapidly changing
regions and each one of these has
potential functional effects on the
cellular circuits that are guided by the
molecular changes within the cell at all
of the timescales you've been hearing
about you just heard about from barnard
for example so I'm going to look very
quickly at some work that's ongoing in
my wet lab at this point to look at one
of the areas that's exciting to me the
mystery is how we got to be cognitively
the way we are among all of these other
vertebrates something changed after we
diverge from the chimpanzee something
during the last five million years which
caused our brains to be qualitatively
and quantitatively different they're
certainly much larger about three times
larger than they were just a few million
years ago and they have other capacities
like speech and language that are
distinct in humans so what were the
molecular changes to the DNA that
actually might have contributed to that
in other words what makes us human this
is a huge question and I'm not going to
even a pro
chin answer but just give you a flavor
for the kinds of things you can do to
ask and and try to answer that question
so in our laboratory we take induced
pluripotent stem cells and we
differentiate them into neurons and I
won't go through the process here but
you can actually grow them into little
pseudo brains in a dish so each one of
these features is like a little piece of
a cortex with the ventricle in the
middle you have radio what are
essentially radial glial cells that are
producing neurons which migrate out and
form layers of the cortex your real
cortex has six layers we get about two
layers out of this the innermost layers
and we can stain them for various
markers pac-6 is a marker for these
cells that are proliferating the early
progenitors TBR is a marker for more
mature neurons we can see that there is
an organization that mimics what's in
the actual brain so this is called a
neural rosette or aneros fear and we can
grow them in a dish now we do this for
human and we do this for rhesus monkey
so this is the original embryonic stem
cell in this case we also do as I
mentioned induced pluripotent stem cells
which are very very similar to embryonic
stem cells and then over a five week
course they develop these cortical like
structures called neurospheres now five
weeks in a human gets you to the
equivalent place of five what we call
rhesus weeks a recent week is five days
instead of seven days so though
everything is sped up a little bit in
the rhesus and we can compare we can
measure at each stage what genes are
changing which genes are more expressed
or less expressed and this is a heat map
that shows you the different patterns of
jeans red means highly expressed at that
time point so these are the weeks as you
march through in human the weeks as you
march through in rhesus
one of these rows is a gene you can see
we've clustered them into jeans that are
primarily on at the embryonic stem cells
so these are genes that are responsible
for maintaining the embryonic stem cell
status and then there are other genes
that come on later so only during neural
differentiation are only late in the
mature neurons at the end of the period
but there are striking difference when
you when you look at these genes and
cluster them there are some cases where
you see striking differences here's a
case where we have genes that come on
very early in neural development in
human and they stay on all the way
through week four whereas in rhesus they
sharply end at resis week two you can
hear you can see kind of a trajectory of
that this is strongly statistically
different and what we're seeing here are
essentially the kinds of changes that
are involved in extra proliferation so
we're making more cells in the in the in
the human culture and also delayed
maturity of the neurons that you see
here more explicitly I won't go to this
just as just kind of eye candy to see
the kind of results that we get but
these are the results on the RNA
sequencing of a gene that's primarily
expressed or exclusively expressed off
for in the embryonic stem cell stage you
can see the expression coming down here
that's correlated with openness of DNA
that we can measure and in front of it a
what's called an enhancer a site that we
can measure with chromatin
immunoprecipitation to the p300 factor
so if three different experimental
methods are concordantly agreeing that
this is highly on in the embryonic stem
cell state you see all the action here
and it's quiet in the neurospheres the
opposite of that is the TBR one as I
said as a marker of mature neurons and
you see that it's on in the neurospheres
at the later time points and it's off
it's very quiet in the embryonic stem
cells so we have very detailed
information about these genes being
expressed and the mechanisms by which
they're expressed so which enhancers
driving them and here's one of these
exciting genes that's different you can
see this gene is on for a long duration
all the way through to week five in
human and terminates its activity after
week two in rhesus now has five as part
of the notch signaling pathway which is
a key regulator of the maturation cycle
of neurons and so we see this as
essentially delayed or prolonged
childhood quote-unquote for these
neurons so these are the two main
operations the main observations that we
have so far we we are seeing genes
associated with neural differentiation
that are delayed and an excessive
proliferation during this time it's very
challenging now to then pin down and
find the precise DNA changes but we know
they're there there are there actual
changes to the DNA sequence among the 15
million changes that separate us from
our common ancestor with chimp are some
of those changes that are made that have
made the difference in this pattern of
neural development and we're intending
to find them and there's a new
technology now where you can one by one
induce those changes into the cells so
we can take human embryonic stem cells
and make them more like rhesus by
putting in specific changes or rhesus
and make them look more like human by
putting its specific DNA changes and
then examining the neuro development
okay part one
part two is a real change of obscene at
this point this is mathematically
inclined audience so I'm going to step
back now and think about this problem as
a whole we as a scientific world have
now at our fingertips thousands of
genomes and soon millions of genomes and
we learn something by comparing the DNA
sequences of two genomes but that turns
out to be a complicated problem and we
know that genomes change by evolution
but the molecular evolution the
footprints of molecular evolution in
genomes are quite complex and that
methodology the theory behind how
genomes change is quite spread over
different fields now so for example you
have a whole field of phylogenetic tree
estimation so deciding what is the
branching order of the different species
based on essentially the number of
changes that separate them you have on
the other hand genome rearrangements
eerie so big pieces of DNA are swapped
in their location so chromosomes are
rearranged over time and you can see
that the order of the genes is different
among in this case different placental
mammals you can compare so this is
large-scale change of order nordion
orientation of large segments you can
compare at the individual base level
small changes single base changes or
insertions or deletions of short runs of
DNA and you do that by assuming that
overall the linear order is the same and
they're only been these insertions and
deletions and substitutions you get a
whole theory of multiple alignment and
optimum multiple lineman of DNA and then
finally we deployed have a process
called recombination where we'll swap
and we'll swap parts of chromosomes that
come from one ancestor or the other and
that creates a path a complicated
structure called an ancestral
recombination graph if you ask how these
recombinations happen to create the
combination of alleles that we see on
current chromosomes allele being a gene
variant all of these currently are
different fields of comparative genomics
that don't talk to each other and
unfortunately most of the models are set
up so they say well let's assume that
there aren't any rearrangements now
we'll focus in on the substitutions or
something like this so by denying all of
the other types of changes they can have
a clean theory of one type of change and
that it does become a problem so we're
striving towards a more uniform theory
and we can use a model called sequence
graphs which are like these Tinkertoy
set ups and i know i'm dating myself
here so it's just really complete this
is really communicate to the younger
generation but these are toys I worked
with in it as a kid and each one of
these you can imagine each one of these
sticks is some kind of piece of DNA and
they're being rearranged and duplicated
in this case and and we may have an
uncertain idea how they are connected to
each other or they may be connected in
different copies in different multiple
ways this kind of model leads to what
we're calling a sequence graph and a
sequence graph is a very simple object
we have segments of DNA you can see
three segments of DNA each one has an
end we'll just call it the left end and
the right end instead of the five prime
end in the three prime end so to get not
to get all biochemical on everybody and
so each one so three segments have six
ends
and then if you want to create a
chromosome of DNA in this case a
circular chromosome for example you can
create the blue one by pasting these two
ends together these are actually
covalent bonds in double-stranded DNA
pasting these two and these two and then
you get a DNA sequence that would be
read this way and then you read this one
in reverse complement which I'm sure
you're all good at this one in reverse
complement and then this one in forward
compliment similarly you could create a
green genome by making two circular
chromosomes one circular chromosome like
this and one that's just this piece
circularized now circular chromosomes
may seem weird to you but our
mitochondria are circular chromosomes
DNA loves to make circles it's as happy
to make circles as it is to make linear
things so that's a part of reality these
things are studied in a in a in a
structure called a breakpoint graph
where the red edges abstractly represent
these sequences and the colored the
other colored edges the blue would
represent one genome configuration in
the green another and the breakpoint
graph tells you in a sense a mini
evolutionary story of how there was a
green configuration at some point and
then there was a blue configuration you
can think about that this is another way
to visualize those that I won't go into
as we're each each node is an entire
sequence and then thereby directed edges
on it but both of these equivalent ways
of visualizing genome evolution are used
extensively in rearrangement theory and
then in the other theories the theory of
substitutions and the theory of
recombination you can think about a time
component so if I was just giving you a
static view of two genomes but if we add
a time component we can imagine that we
started with a single chromosome genome
with four segments of DNA with these
colors and then time goes by
things happen for example this
duplicates and then certain parts of it
are changed this is a summary grass that
we use a lot so the pink thing just goes
on but nothing really changes so i'm not
drawing it here but here you have the
ability to actually draw rearrangement
so you can see that through time you
know these pieces recombine to create a
combined piece with different things in
different orders these lightning bolts
represent substitutions so this starts
the model the full complexity of what
actually happens to DNA segments and
what's happened to our DNA segments over
the last six hundred million years along
with all the other vertebrates now how
do you study this process from a
mathematical point of view so the next
few minutes will be the mathematical
section of this of this talk and I'm
just going to try to stick it stick to
easy easy kinds of general concepts here
and I'll whip through it so the most
developed model for as a stochastic
model for changes in genomes is the
model of the change in an individual
base at a position in the chromosome so
as we go through time an individual base
of DNA either stays the same maybe it's
an a and it stays in a or it switches to
being one of the other bases and the
simplest model for that is this rate
matrix called the Jukes Canada rate
matrix and our is just a rate parameter
and it tells you how fast as a unit in
terms of a time unit right how fast we
are changing from one base to another
it's completely symmetric and we can
write it out as a rate matrix here and
the minus 3 is to get the rose to sum to
0 as is required in a rate matrix and
then if we want to know the probability
of changing over a certain period of
time from one base to another we can
take this rate matrix and put it in the
exponent multiplied by the time T and so
the probability this is
matrix PT is a 4 by 4 matrix and it says
the probability of a changing to any
other letter C changing to any other
letter in time T and it's simply the
exponential of this rate matrix and you
can write out that that always
convergent series and you get it based
on this if we want to actually compute
now the probability of one base changing
to another over a fixed a given period
of time that what we really want to do
is not take powers of the matrix
explicitly that's a waste of time we
actually want to do a spectral
decomposition of the rate matrix and so
we know that these nice symmetric metric
the matrices can always be spectrally
decomposed into a set of orthogonal
projection matrices that we can then
linearly combine to form the rate matrix
and then when we and these are all
mutually orthogonal which is wonderful
because now when we compute this
exponent we can factor out these
cancelling terms and we simply get a
very easy series here so that any power
of it is actually another linear
combination of the same projection
matrices their basis in the matrix space
right and all we have to do is
exponentiate these leading components
which will see if they play the role of
Fourier coefficients a little later so
that's standard and when we do this we
actually then can decompose the matrix
realizes that it realized that it has
two projection matrix here they are and
I point out that these are integer
valued and there's no I priori reason
that they should be integer valued will
return to that and then you combine them
into this equation to get p to t and
then you can write it out in an explicit
form so this form tells you the
probability of going from any base like
here from an a
to a G in time T with radar is exactly
that number so the space of
configurations of the entire genomes is
more complicated we were just focusing
on one position in the genome and
looking how it changed through time but
let's look at a very simple genomespace
suppose we only had two genes and they
were their order and orientation was
being changed through genome time
through evolutionary time so if you make
the simplifying assumption that every
chromosome is circular it just gets rid
of a lot of special cases then there's
really only three configurations for a
two gene genome either each gene is in
its own circular chromosome or they're
both in the same chromosome oriented
this way or they're both in the same
chromosome oriented that way relative to
each other there's only three
configurations and if that's the whole
configuration space of two gene genomes
then there's some rate at which one
configuration changes to another and
that has to do with the rate at which
pieces of chromosome are broken and
paste it back together again by
so-called to break rearrangement so we
can apply our same trick that's the rate
matrix there's three states now we have
genome states by genome States and it
looks a lot like the juke scanner matrix
we decompose it into projection matrices
in a spectral decomposition and we get
an explicit formula for the probability
of going from one global genome
rearrangements state to another let's
try three gene genomes okay so now we're
talking about genomes with three genes
in them there are 15 different
configurations shown here using my
compact notion for genomes with the
double with the by directed edges and
each one of these will have a particular
rate are on it and indicates that I can
go from one genome to the other with one
to break rearrangement which means cut
in two places get for free ends paste
them back together again so one
elementary operation if we generalize
this we are led to a theory in which for
engine genomes there are this many to n
minus 1 times 2n minus 3 and so forth
different states that I can be in those
are the different arrangements and they
correspond to matchings if it wasn't
already obvious already I'm essentially
taking two ND if I have n jeans I have
twice that many ends and I can match
them in any way I want and create a
genome and so really what we're talking
about is the stochastic process on
matchings turns out that it's been
studied extensively daya coniston homes
did some beautiful work and specifically
mentioned some of the properties daikon
it was the first to really estimate the
asymptotic mixing time for this very
very accurately and then there are a
number of other areas in which this has
been a powerful area now the theory of
this is quite beautiful and I'm only
going to sketch it and I hope you'll get
the gist of it in this so it actually
turns out this this turns out to be both
the Jukes cantor in this process and
others turn out to be a general members
of a general class of processes so
homogeneous space is simply a set with a
group that acts on it very very general
framework at this point that's called a
homogeneous space what we're interested
is when the group is the permutation
group so that's a very simple kind of
group in particular we can think about
representing a matching so here I have
to I have the numbers 1 to 2 N in some
order will call them I 1 is the first
number and so
what then a matching is just saying that
end is matched to that in that end is
matched to that end so that is a genome
for me or a matching and if I apply a
permutation to that matching all I'm
going to do is permute the individual
components and I'm going to get another
matching right so that operation so that
group of permutations acts on the
matching taking one genome and giving
you another genome you can think about
it like this if i start with the genome
apply permutation i'm going to get
another genome i might apply another
permutation i might stay at that genome
if it gives me another representation of
what is essentially the same matching
and then it goes on like this so this is
a random walk by action on the group so
for any case when you have a group
acting on a set you can ask for
arbitrary member and by symmetry within
the group it doesn't matter which you
choose you can ask what is the
stabilizer of that point so I'm going to
choose an Origin x0 some genome and ask
what are what is the subset of all group
elements that leave that fixed and
that's called the stabilizer it's a
subgroup not a normal subgroup
necessarily but a subgroup so we can
write the quotient g / h is a set of
left cosets of that again since it's not
necessarily normal back x itself is not
a group but it is a well defined object
and these cosets turn out to be
isomorphic to X itself so you can think
about X as the as the action is the
product of moving from one left coset to
another and that tells you the size of X
by the way it must be the size of the
symmetric group which is 2n factorial so
symmetric group on to n elements is 2n
factorial divided by the size of the
stabilizer subgroup well the stabilizer
subgroup is very simple it's the hyper
octahedral group because I have a
matching I can swap any of the order of
the individual pairs and I haven't
changed the matching or I can change the
order of the pairs and I haven't changed
the matching so that turns out to be the
group
of symmetries of the N cube and that has
size n factorial times 2 to the N you
take the ratio of these and that is then
the size of my space of matchings so
hamad homogeneous space is a very very
nice object and we can think about the
group acting on it and what we actually
want to think about is the group acting
not on two on one genome but two genomes
at once so when a when a permutation
acts on two genomes at once it gives me
the pre muted version of the first
genome and the / muted version of the
second genome as a pair and if you trace
now through the space you can follow
this under all possible permutations and
you get what's called an orbital so this
is the class of all genomes that are
similar pairs of genomes that are that
that have the same essential difference
from each other so the set of these
orbitals index what we call the
different set if you think about this we
we've introduced the Jukes Cantor model
where the space is just the four bases
we've introduced this model where the
face is the genome but there's another
space that's very interesting the
Fourier space where the elements are 0 1
2 up to n minus 1 in the discrete
Fourier space and if you look at the
differences between those two elements
then this is the set of differences of
this Fourier space it's another simple
homogeneous space so this is a good
example now the differences in the case
of genomes are quite easy to work out
here's a genome that we saw before with
a red with a blue genome here's a
sequence craft that we saw before with a
blue genome and a green genome we can
see this is how the breakpoint graph
looks so I'm labeling now each of the
ends of the of the DNA segments 6 ends
they can be paired in the green pairing
or matched in the matched in the green
pairing matched in the blue pairing we
don't really care about the numbers here
because when I act on permutations I can
permute those arbitrarily so what's
essential is just the topology of this
thing
and the topology of this thing has to be
alternating cycles of green blue edge
and and they have so you have to have an
even number we have to break this into
an even number of sub components that
must sum to six nodes or three if you
divide by two and so this represents a
partition of the number three two and
one and in fact I can get all three
partitions of the number 31 11 would be
when the genomes are identical to each
other to one when there's one swap and
three when all three things were swapped
around so there's really only three
fundamental differences between two to
three gene genomes the structure of the
difference between two genomes always
has to be a partition of the number
three now that's important because we
can then study a process that's
symmetric so we think about doing a
random walk on genomes I want the
probability of taking the next step to
only depend on the structure of the
change the orbital in which the change
is and in that case I can have any
function I want a probability function
or in general in a complex function and
now I can iterate that function as I
walk through the space now the beautiful
thing is once I have this so-called
radial function which depends only on
the difference and not on the individual
state that you're in then I can map that
down it induces a unique function on X
and on the group G and the nice thing
about the functions on the group G is we
know how to convulsion so this is the
definition of convolution of two
functions on the group G I take a group
element gamma I can break it down in all
possible ways as alpha followed by beta
within the group and some over f of
alpha times G of data that's the normal
notion of convolution you can see that
that actually if these are probability
distributions this corresponds to conv
olvidaba bility distributions how am i
doing
I got a lot more okay good so in that
case we have this space now that's that
where we can do convolution of functions
so we can talk about functions on our
state space and we have this natural
notion of product of functions as
convolution which is appropriate for the
parameters that for the for the model
that we're thinking of because in a
random walk the probability distribution
progresses by successive convolutions
matrix multiplications essentially as
you go out there is a special type of
homogeneous space called a Gelfond space
and you know we just heard about israel
Gelfond from bernard yeah so I put this
on so delfin realized that in fact for
these special kinds of homogeneous
spaces wonderful things happen and they
are exactly the spaces for which
convolution is commutative so if
convolution commutes actually the math
becomes very very nice and there are a
limited case of these in particular the
juke scanner space is one the discrete
Fourier space is another famous one and
the space of engine genomes is all
they're all examples of these beautiful
Gelfond spaces what makes them so nice
is that they each have a Fourier
transform which converts convolution
into simple multiplication that makes
things very very nice now we're all
familiar with the Fourier transform for
the Fourier space but the beautiful
thing about this is that every Gelfond
space has one of these and in particular
it's characterized the Fourier transform
is characterized by a particular
set of functions there are thigh agonal
set of radial functions which are
usually called the normalized spherical
functions and when we make a matrix out
of these we get a Fourier transform in
the D space the space of all differences
so any function written on differences
you just take its complex conjugate
multiply it by this and you'll get its
Fourier transform value in particular as
i said this converts convolution into
simple multiplication and here's the
here's the way here's a way of saying
that esque involved with G is simply
taking the d for every possible distance
you look at the Fourier coefficient the
coefficient of the Fourier transform of
F and the coefficient of Fourier
transform of D and waited by the
appropriate coefficient in the deep
spherical function and add them up and
there you there you go so these bites
not the coefficient sorry this is the
entire spherical function deep spherical
function so this absolutely is is very
beautiful and we're very very lucky to
have one there are really only few nice
infinite families of Gelfond spaces with
whether symmetric group operates on
everyone for all n these discrete spaces
so now we're going back to our original
motivation for this we wanted a spectral
decomposition so it turns out that the
spectral decomposition is highly
associated with the inverse fourier
transform so the inverse fourier
transform looks like this this is the
weight these are the spherical functions
again that's an entire vector and a
whole function there and the radial
functions and so forth can be
represented as matrices as well as
vectors so there's an a beautiful
equivalence you can embed them in a
subset of the matrix space and they
become essentially these projection
matrices so I'm going to just give you
I'm not going to go through the math
give you a quick example so it turns out
that for the Juke scanner model be the
spherical the normalized unnormalized
spherical functions are 1 1 transpose in
other words the vector 1 1 the vector
3-1 those are the two functions that you
need to understand this this is in
different space the different space for
the Jukes canter is either on the same
or I'm different there's only two states
that those are very very simple
functions and when you transform that
into the x by x space you get these two
matrices which you will recognize are
exactly our projection matrices and
that's how we got our beautiful spectral
decomposition of this whole process now
you'll notice again though Oh finally
why is this so important because now if
we do n fold convolution then by B
equivalence of multiplication we just
get a knife power of the Fourier
coefficient here in front and then by
Taylor expansion we can expand any
analytical function in particular
exponent and we get this form which
you'll see is the completely general
form of the what we did before with the
Juke scanner model so that means once i
have the fourier transform i can have an
analytic solution to all of these models
in terms of the probability of
transforming from one state to another
in any time t given by this simple
equation so this holds for a broad class
of the spectral decomposition then holds
for the entire broad broad class of
Galvan spaces the Fourier transform
matrix is just the concatenation of the
individual spherical functions so
remember the spherical function for the
Fourier transform was 11 3-1 you
concatenate those that's the Fourier
transform that I was talking about
earlier so in the in the standard
Fourier transform equation so the
wonderful thing about this is
that the coefficients are integers in
this which surprised the hell out of me
I've slowly trying to come to understand
that in a deeper way it has to do with
group representation theory and some
interesting facts but but these are
actually integers for every gal fun
space so here it is for the space if you
have two genomes or matching on four
things that's the process that we first
started out remember that little three
state process that's the Fourier
transform matrix for three genes this is
the Fourier transform matrix for four
genes this is the Fourier transform
matrix and these numbers are big Eiling
and I have spent hours and hours staring
at them the bad news is that there is no
known computationally tractable
closed-form formula for those integers
and so there's your open problem I would
really really like to have a fast
Fourier transform or even any kind of
analytical Fourier transform for genome
rearrangements we don't nevertheless
it's an absolutely gorgeous theory of
symmetric Gelfond spaces and I committed
to you as a nice thing to work on if we
had that analytical function you could
you could you could actually compute an
exact probability model for all T
including duplications gains and losses
does complicate this and so I'm not
trying to shove everything under the rug
ok now I'm going to switch back to
biology how much time do I have
10 minutes oh that's unfortunate okay I
went over on the map okay okay
completely switch back comparative
genomics in cancer up before I start so
there's one thing that we really care
about in cancer is how the mutations in
the tumor have screwed up the genome
that's the one thing and for the first
time now we can take a biopsy if
someone's tumor compare it to their DNA
in their normal cells and say AHA these
are the mutations that have changed your
genome that may be driving the tumor to
grow in an uncontrolled fashion and be a
cancer the cannot emphasize to you how
exciting it is that for the first time
in medical history we're actually able
to read the entire genome of a cancer
tumor so that is exciting and when we
understand the specific changes that are
driving the tumor we can give a drug not
like chemotherapy which kills every
dividing cell but a drug that's targets
only cells with that mutation in their
genome and you can get this okay this is
a patient with metastatic melanoma he
has a tumor that's driven or actually
you can see hundreds of tumors all over
his body that are driven by cells that
contain a specific mutation in the b-raf
gene for which rush developed a
brilliant drug called vemurafenib and
when this patient got this drug 15 weeks
later he was working out at the gym and
swimming in the pool one of the most
remarkable cut recoveries from
metastatic melanoma on record that is
the power of a precision therapy and it
didn't make him sick like chemotherapy
unfortunately at 23 weeks he looked like
this and if you mapped as you can see
the tumors are coming back in their
exact same locations the problem here is
very much like our treatment of HIV AIDS
if you hit it with just one mono therapy
it evolved around that all it takes is
one of these cells in this tumor to be
resistant to this therapy and it will
come roaring back or become resistant to
this mono therapy so we got to hit him
with a cocktail or or an adaptive immune
response like trigger the immunity the
immune response of the host to attack
the cancer in order to understand that
we have to understand the complexity of
cancer and the reason that we're not
able to do that today is no longer that
we can't sequence these genomes but I
want to give you the punchline if I run
at a time the reason is because we won't
share the data that we get that's the
reason and you have to fight against
that so right now medical centers are
gearing up to collect massive amounts of
this data and hold it to themselves we
have to change that because by bringing
together truly large data sets in
comparative genomics we will be able to
find the combinations of patterns that
occur in cancer that could lead to a new
cure for the disease the future is this
a patient gets sequenced that's his
tumor it's compared to a database of
more than a million different cancer
genomes worldwide based on the
similarity and experiences that we've
had with these other patients the doctor
gives them a targeted cancer therapy
treatment that's the future we have to
create the Cancer Genome Atlas is
currently the largest program in the
world generating cancer genomes it's
targeting 20 adult cancers 500 tumors
from each one 500 matched normal samples
the data is being generated by these
laboratories and
these laboratories are analyzing it
including our laboratory at Santa Cruz
and all of this data flows to a database
called CGHUB and I'm proud to have built
that database it's now the largest
database in the world of cancer genomes
we're aiming towards 5 petabytes scaling
to fifty thousand genomes and we have a
number of innovations that I won't go
into technical technical things that
make it easy to use but we could do a
lot more these are just some stats we
downloaded 10 petabytes of data to
different users over the last six months
typically you get about two to four
gigabits per second so that's CGHUB but
we actually are going to need a network
an international network of databases of
genomes not just for cancer but also for
inherited diseases and other conditions
where the human genome sequence can
inform medicine and if we look at this
this is work with Dave Patterson and you
can get the you can get the tech report
on this if you look at the requirements
for a million genomes there is a
substantial amount of engineering that
has to go into scaling this up but it's
all it's all doable and I'm not going to
go through this for for lack of time but
there are a number of things that we
want to do we know how to do we just
need the chance to do this and many of
us are getting together in a consortium
now to try to push this and a lot of the
medical centers are signing on in the
database that they've
arson and I worked on you would have the
raw sequencing data down here you would
have an intermediate level that looks
like the sequence graph level that I
described like an abstract level for
describing genomes and then at the top
you would have the clinical data in the
interpretation so building this three
layer structure is essential for us to
understand genomes we can do it if you
look at we estimated Dave and I
estimated it would be about a hundred
petabytes even if we kept every bit of
usable information from those genome
sequencing runs and that's only about
two months of youtube growth so we have
the technology to to capture this we
there are a number of other ways to
think about this but i'll note that
again for other diseases that are
actually easier than cancer from an
informatics point of view now i want to
give you a feel really quickly and this
will just be a bunch of visuals that you
see what DNA sequencing data actually
looks like from a cancer genome so
here's from an ovarian cancer from our t
CJ this is out of our database you see
the DNA read and you can see it matching
to the DNA sequence and these DNA weeds
are all funny in the sense that they
match this is a abstract version these
are all the reads 02 a long piece of
chromosome there are a bunch of reads
that match here but then continue on
matching over here so these are reads
that are split over these two regions in
a funny way and you see there's extra
reads here so what's happened is about
500,000 bases have been duplicated in
tandem so there's two copies in a row in
the cancer genome and this is the point
where it kind of switches back to see
the second copy and we can see this live
in in action
down right 10 to the base base pair
exactly what's happening so i can tell
you precise to the base pair what
happened to these 500,000 odd bases in
that cancer genome i'm going to skip
over this we've done a lot of
benchmarking on how people call
different mutations both point mutations
and rearrangements that you see here
drawing in a circle now the chromosomes
are around a circle and you can see
rearrangements that bring this DNA in
contact with this this DNA in contact
with this so these this is another view
of sequence graphs so these are the
sequence graphs that I was talking about
built in it in a different way that's
more commonly seen in the literature but
those sequins graphs derived from two
different sources also have some
agreement now our laboratory in addition
to studying neurodevelopment my wet lab
studies gliomas so we have gliomas and
the worst kind of gliomas glioblastoma
that's the most aggressive kind of brain
cancer that arrives from the rises from
the glia so with studying the whole
genomes from 17 different glioblastoma
zeeeee we can see not that there's a
random pattern of rearrangements but
rearrangements have occurred
specifically which deleted this gene and
in order to actually get cancer you have
to delete both copies of the gene you
get two chromosomes right one for mom
one from dad both of the all of these
people started out with two copies of
this gene in one case they lost almost
an entire chromosome and that's a very
common event in cancer actually and the
second case they had a focal loss
pinpointed around that gene and we know
the reason for that the cancer there's
absolutely cellular vital gene right
next to this gene and so the cancer
tends to throw out large things but if
it tries to throw out large pieces of
both copies then it also gets the
critical gene so the second hip has to
be a pinpoint hit for you to actually
successfully be a cancer
and it always is one of these events
really struck us and it turns out to be
actually common 10% of gliomas have this
property where we actually see that the
rearrangement wasn't a to break
rearrangement or a three break
rearrangement it was like a hundred
break rearrangement the genome was
literally shattered at a certain point
into a hundred little pieces and the
endpoints of those pieces were pasted
back together again in what appears to
be a random form we've now found this
dozens of times and through the
rearrangement theory that I described in
the mathematical portion of this talk we
are able to reconstruct what the tumor
looks like and if you imagine you brick
you create all these pieces now start
pasting together the ends in a random
matching you will create circular pieces
just by chance right and Tropic argument
there's a lot of more ways to create
these little circles and those are
actually seen in cancer so here's a
brain cancer where we traced out the
exact base pair links all the way around
and created this circle which turns out
to be highly amplified and it has a very
important cancer driver gene so this
cancer not only deletes the brakes which
were a cdkn2a which we talked about but
it has an accelerator pedal on this this
mdm2 that is on a circular chromosome
which is enlarged copies all of this
pink area are copies of this circular
chromosome in this fluorescence in situ
hybridization of that cancer so we know
the circular chromosome exists and by
complete DNA sequencing we can actually
see it we actually see traces of it in
the blood sample it is so pervasive in
answer I won't go to you I won't go over
for the medical audience there's the
highlights of studying 500 gliomas I
think we've learned a lot about
glioblastoma from this I'm going to skip
the medical details of that I'm going to
leave you with one caveat from a
mathematical point of view it turns out
that I've been simplifying things as if
the tumor had just one genome it turns
out that individual cells in the tumor
can have different genomes and they're
all kind of competing for who can grow
than fastest and who can be the nastiest
cancer cell that makes it a little
complicated and this is a diagram of how
you have these so-called subclones
within tumors and we actually are now
measuring the sub tonality of tumors we
have a mathematical model for that which
I will skip entirely for lack of times
but we can essentially deke involve the
mixture of all the genomes using a
mathematical mixture decomposition and
the rearrangement theory that I just
told you about and coming from the raw
data we start with something like this
where there's evidence for a loop back
and an extra copy of DNA here like we
saw before the mathematical model takes
that noisy data and hypothesizes a
particular a particular percentage of
the DNA that has this that becomes a sub
clone that is characterized by this
extra piece of DNA same thing with a
deletion here and then we can count the
number of subclones finally the last
thing that happens when we analyze
cancer genomes as we see that there's
not just one change like seat loss of
cdk and to be and a lives you see up
here blue is loss or amplification of
MDM
red is amplification so we see not only
are the do we lose the break so to speak
on cell growth and gain accelerators to
cell growth but we see patterns in
multiple different pathways of
interaction where changes are all doing
are all happening and they're all in the
direction of accelerating the cancer
those are the driver events and that's
where the new drug is going to come in
and interact and kill the cancer cells
preferably but we need to decompose all
of these pathways of interaction and
have an integrative data model we're
working on that from the point of view
of a of a global model involving Markov
essentially markup random fields or
Bayesian nets so there a number of
pathways for this so I need to finish up
this is in summary the age of
opportunity at this point not only to
understand from genomes how we got to be
the way we are but to help cure
ourselves to understand what happens in
medicine when the genome goes wrong we
can read entire genomes at this point it
is an extraordinary issue extraordinary
opportunity but we have a huge
infrastructure issue now those data are
being held in silos and we need to break
the silos I need your help there the
interpretive challenge is immense to
actually have a mathematical model of
how whole genomes change is an unsolved
problem at this point and to be able to
interpret them in light of the cellular
pathways is an unsolved problem we need
work on there but it will accelerate
biomedical work so let me thank some
collaborators particular the day
Patterson group the people I'm working
with on this large international project
to to break the silos and share data are
listed here Richard Durbin on a new data
model for genomes broad and others and
this is the can't
group at Santa Cruz thank you
much too much man I usually put the back
partying in that thanks for an
extraordinary talk we can take a couple
of questions yes
yes
I'm glad you bring up the immune system
so we are also sequencing the t-cells
and b-cells so that we can see the
specific arrangements the rearrangements
that happen in those cells so those
cells actually rearrange so called V DJ
parts of them rearrange that creates a
molecular diversity that the immune
system uses to recognize any foreign
peptide that might be a threat to it or
or not right and so its failure or
success is vital to our help so genome
sequencing can actually read the status
of the immune system we can read which
clones are being made in that now that
called phones the t-cell i can read
which t cell phones are being made by
the immune system i need to match those
to the proteins that they interact with
that's an unsolved problem that's a very
difficult computational problem but if
we solve that yes absolutely the immune
system to another great opportunity I do
this in our lab as well we're at we're
looking at a disease called ankylosing
spondylitis and where we're looking at
Blooming of different immune cell
populations clonal populations in
response to the disease yes yes
the performances are
why they turned out the lights
that's the world what can I say the
group you know it's it's basically it's
basically group theory and the beauty of
the group Theory drives it but then but
it's the final the final part of the
symmetry of that that makes it all
integer and nice is is the icing on the
cake so it's a it's a special subset of
group theory that's very very tractable
except for the fact that we don't have a
closed-form formula for the actual
Fourier transform yes
how cancer involves that actually see or
simulate what a treat how effective the
trees we could we could we're just now
starting to get that that type of data
so you want it you want to actually do
the genome at the first diagnosis you
want to do the genome again after the
first treatment when the tumor has
shrunk but not disappeared you want to
do it again three years later when it
recurs and and when we have those kinds
of data will have lots of information
about what work and what didn't work and
how cells emerge resistance to the
particular therapy that was applied we
only have a limited amount of data of
that type at this point but we hope to
get more the scene
in visions you could not like
a gigantic number of different regions
possibly look at or I mean you have
unfortunately yes if you want to use
small molecule drugs right the kind of
typical drug you taken a pill then
they're going to have to be an enormous
amount of them luckily there are 800
different compounds that are currently
on the market or in the pipeline
specific target specific genes that are
known to be involved in cancer and so if
we can get to the point where we can
take combinations of those 800 there are
an enormous amount of therapies but
we'll never I'm going to go back to the
Atari quick soapboxing we will never get
there if we do this by standard clinical
trials right five years to test this
combination another five years to test
this combination the only way we'll do
that is to build this database that's a
constant learning system where we can
see all of the data at once smart
algorithms are figuring out what is
working and what's not working and
extrapolating forget the standard
clinical trial approach to this we need
the computer geeks to get at this with
big data one this question yes
how would you say our ability to the
technician can certify
sorry how much would you say are going
to the technical
yeah it's become essentially a
computational problem how to precisely
characterize the structural changes in
cancer cells and where it's a very
active area of algorithmic development I
quickly showed you a comparison between
our program and the program at the Broad
Institute in Boston and they agree about
the 75 percent of the time and we're
still working out you know why what's
what's going on with the other cases
some of it could be these subclones
where you know there's some cells that
have one structural form and another and
it's right at the limit of your
detectability thanks again David